learn about event driven architecture
with this comprehensive course event
driven architecture is a software design
pattern where the flow of the program is
determined by events such as user
actions sensor outputs or messages
passing between processes join Matt
Marts and Matt Morgan as they unravel
the secrets of transforming traditional
apps into Cutting Edge event-driven
powerhouses Welcome to our Deep dive
into event driven architecture on AWS in
this course we'll be going over what
event-driven architecture is along with
migrating an example Inventory
management app to event driven
architecture we also have a companion
blog post that is linked throughout the
course at mars.
codde I'm Matt Marts I've been an AWS
Community Builder since the first cohort
in October of
2020 the AWS Community Builder program
is an incred incredible platform for
networking with AWS professionals both
inside and outside of AWS along with a
few other perks if that sounds
interesting to you their application
cycle tends to open at the beginning of
the calendar year so keep an eye out for
that I'm also a principal software
architect at definitive at definitive we
have an event-driven architecture backed
IOS app called Savvy spin smart that
helps people save
money in this course we'll dive into
Hands-On coding for event driven
architecture using AWS cdk if you're new
to cdk you might find my cdk crash
course with free code Camp particularly
useful for deeper insights into Dev
tools event driven architecture and
server lless you could also check out my
blog at matt. mars. codes where I share
Advanced knowledge and
tips uh thanks Matt I'm also Matt I'm
Matt Morgan I'm also AWS Community
Builder joined at the same time as Matt
Mart I've been in the program for about
three years uh I'm currently employed as
a director of engineering at comold
which is a multi Channel live selling
platform uh I've done a lot of writing
uh I co-authored a book called the
typescript workshop and uh I have a lot
of other blog posts and things and
everything is linked uh as well as some
talks linked from my website which is at
Matt morgan.
Cloud over the course of this video
we'll take a look at Eda Basics such as
terminology item potency and why you
need to car about it and synchronous and
asynchronous response
models then we'll build an Eda app using
cdk making sure to add in observability
and things like
that and we'll wrap the course up by
going over some Advanced practices such
as considerations for how to format your
events along with some neat tools that
AWS
provides so to help demonstrate the
value of event rate architecture we came
up with a little sample
application uh and a problem to solve in
the application so so the application is
a warehouse Inventory management system
called whims because we've got a
warehouse full of McGuffin and the
McGuffin is a very popular item and so
we need software to help us manage uh
things like Inventory management uh
fulfillment uh Payment Processing all
those kinds of things whims is was V1 is
built as uh a microservice uh rest API
systems everything is a synchronous rest
API call um and this is uh this is fine
at a smaller scale but as as uh the
system begins to grow up we find that um
some of the
uh some of the Lambda functions inside
the architecture uh are doing too many
different things and we start to see
some some weaknesses in the architecture
so we're going to go into um into this
application get a little bit deeper into
it and uh examine some of those problems
and then examine the solution uh that we
solved with event DP
so let's look ahead at what we're going
to be building by the end of this course
uh what we want to do is we want to take
our a tightly coupled uh entirely rest
based microservice and change it into an
Aventure an architecture where uh things
happen are eventually consistent and
have a single responsibility for
component uh the way this will work is
that um when an order is submitted via
the API Gateway that's going to be
persisted in a dynb table and then we'll
use Dynamo DB
streams and event Bridge pipes in order
to transform that to transform that
event uh and then uh and then emit it
across event bridge where we can create
rules to capture the events and then
trigger other things so in the diagram
you can see that we're triggering a
number of things off the event Bridge
rule uh we can have our low inventory
warning there uh we can eventually build
an external fulfillment system off of
that we have event logs and we're going
to trigger a step function that is going
to handle things like adjusting
inventory and processing payments and we
know that one of the weaknesses of our
payment system is that we sometimes get
rate limited uh by the payment system so
we're going to use sqs to slow down uh
the rate of uh events going into the
payment system so that everything can be
processed in due
time a few reminders before we get
started there's a companion blog post
that reinforces what we'll be going over
here the video is split up into chapters
and we'll have timestamped links in the
description and the sections are
colorcoded the intro and outro are blue
the Eda basic section will be green the
demo will be orange and the advanced or
best practices section will be purple
now that that's out of the way let's get
some backend on what event driven
architecture
is Eric Johnson is a renowned principal
developer Advocate at AWS he's widely
recognized for his expertise and
insightful talks on a venten
architecture in his various
presentations Eric distills Eda to its
core and he simp simplifies it
brilliantly as something happens and
then you
react this succinct phrase captures the
essence of event driven architecture but
what does it mean in
practice it's helpful to think of in
terms of our daily
experiences as humans we're surrounded
by a continuous stream of events these
could be anything from a phone
notification to a sudden change in the
weather interestingly we don't respond
to every single event we selectively
react based on relevancy urgency or our
current focus and this selective
reaction is a key aspect of event driven
architecture it's about systems
intelligently responding to specific
events events that
matter in the realm of software and
Cloud architecture this translates to
applications and services reacting to
certain triggers or changes in the
environment just like us these systems
are designed to respond selectively
ensuring efficiency and relevance in
their
operations Eric Johnson's analogy
beautifully aligns with this principle
making Eda not just a technical concept
but a relatable natural
process so
why do you think Eda is becoming so
popular well I think that uh you know in
many of the tools that we like to work
with increase developer productivity
when you increase developer productivity
uh you build more and when you build
more you end up with more features and
when you end up with more features then
uh you start complexity really starts to
creep into the system uh and um we've
all seen like um you know a thousand
functions that try to do way too many
things and uh are really hard to to
modify so I think it's natural to say um
that my system is getting really big and
complex so I want to start to make it
into a distributed system I want to
start to to break Services out I want to
start having things happen uh when
something else happens and decouple uh
these services in a way that uh makes it
easier to build a wide broad system that
has lots of complexity but that the
complexity can be siloed and contained
within
Services yeah that plus like fa
tolerance and you get a highly reactive
system that it's easy to extend like as
a you can throw an intern at a problem
and say Hey you know add this feature to
it you don't have to worry about the
intern breaking the entire monolith
Lambda that's handling your order system
right yeah I mean if if the intern is
breaking it that's probably my fault
anyway for um asking someone like that
but but yeah I mean it's um I think that
isolating failure to one service as
opposed to my whole system Falls over is
a really really important design
consideration I also think that um you
know we we find uh opportunities where
we want systems to scale
independently uh one system uh you know
maybe uh can't take too much traffic and
another system can can go very quickly
we have different levels of importance
on on some of the capabilities that we
do some some some capabilties we might
say oh eventually consistency is fine
like that can happen overnight or you
know it can happen later other things we
may need an immediate response it's very
hard to build systems that way when
everything is sort of contained within
one function everything just has to kind
of happen see synchronously one after
another but if you can emit an event
that says uh you know something that an
order has come in or a new customer
signed up or a payment is whatever it is
and and then uh hook into that and say
okay and then I want this to happen uh
that can be a really powerful way to
build and the other thing that I think
um is really important here is that a
lot of us who've been in the business
for a while have seen systems that sort
of start with you know lots of rest
interactions and things like that and
then eventually we
say we can't do everything inside of uh
one rest call so we need something that
happens some kind of process that will
happen
offline or in the background and often
the solution to that has been CW so like
every five minutes a process wakes up
and says do I have anything to do and
maybe it has to query a database to do
that uh or maybe there's you know some
other way that that it can do that and
and that kind of system can be um you
know it's first of all if uh if it wakes
up and says any work to do right now oh
there isn't and then a job comes in
right after that it's going to wait
until the next interval so it's slower
uh also it's frequently waking up and
saying do I have any work to do and
finding out the answer is no so it's
inefficient uh if you can instead say uh
here's an event react to the event and
then have a system that's kind of
standing by ready to do that uh you're
going to be in a much better place and
and the tools that we have now to do
that build that kind of architecture uh
things like Lambda step functions event
Bridge those are great tools and they do
a really good job for it so by switching
to from like a cron based server full
like Legacy PHP system running once a
day or something like that to more of an
event-driven architecture it enables
your teams to more quickly react to
things and actually process data closer
to On
Demand that's right yeah and and um I
think that um part of this is is that
it's important to embrace eventual
consistency and to say that things are
not happening within that um you know
the the 29 second API Gateway uh timeout
or or um whatever it is you're working
with um but on the other hand if you
build uh event driven architecture in a
really good way that you can often find
that things are happening very quickly
uh and and it almost seems like it's
happening in real time yeah that's a
good point and I don't think we haven't
gone over eventual consistency yet in
this course and maybe maybe editor match
should go back and add some slides on it
but uh what what is involved in getting
into that eventual consistency
mindset you know I don't think I think I
think it's just just thinking about it
really because um because the web is
already prepped us for that in fact even
before the web was um such a big part of
our Lives we were um you know it was
part of our lot it was part of
um it was part of culture it it was
something it was understood I'm waiting
for a check to clear for example right
uh I received a payment but that payment
is eventually consistent and the funds
are not available for me to use I mean
that's that's been uh you know around
longer than I have uh so you know and I
think that um I think payments are a
great example of that but but I also
feel
like if you just understand that that
the web is by by its nature eventually
consistent of course you can you can
contrive of of uh uh conditions where uh
you don't want that eventual consistency
and there are tools for that too but but
as by taking uh eventual consistency I
know you we're also talking about item
potency here which I think I think kind
of goes along with that uh and saying
that that's the default starting place
that's where I want to be uh when I'm
designing my system and anything uh that
uh isn't uh living up to those
principles is an
exception do you find it difficult to
maybe do you have to push back on maybe
product people about the whole eventual
consistency aspect I've never really had
a problem with that um I think that uh
I I I don't I don't want to I don't want
to beat up on devs at all really uh
because devs are great people but most
of the time in my career I found that
the reason that a system is uh was built
in immediately consistent way it's just
because of we just built it as rest and
then that became of the expectation um
when I when I go and say um you know hey
we're going to put a spinner on the page
and then then poll until this report is
ready or something like that to a
product person I've never had any push
back on that I I think that um you know
as I said in the first place uh it's
it's very normal for uh many things in
our lives to have that kind of eventual
consistency mailing a letter I mean like
uh you know that's that's been around
for hundreds of years and uh and
everyone's had that expectation and I
think that um you know that that should
just be part of our uh expectation when
it comes to development
too great all right let's uh let's move
on and start talking about uh what an
actual event is and item potency and all
those things we just discussed all
right thanks Matt to fully grasp
event-driven architecture it's essential
to understand its core components so
let's dive into four key terms that are
fundamental to event Ren
architecture first up an event you can
think of an event as a record of
something that has already happened it's
a historical fact immutable and
unchangeable an event is not about the
current state of the system but rather a
specific occurrence or action that has
taken place in the
past next we have a producer a producer
is the source of events it generates and
sends out events to signify that
something has
happened this could be anything from a
user action like clicking a button to a
system change like a completed
transaction now let's talk about the
consumer a consumer is the recipient of
events it's designed to react or respond
to the event it receives this reaction
could be anything from updating a
database sending a notification or
triggering a new process or
workflow finally we have the
channel this is the conduit through
which events are transmitted from
producer users to
Consumers the channel ensures that
events reach their intended destinations
and it's the infrastructure that
supports the flow and management of
events acting like a bridge between
producers and
consumers now let's unpack the concept
of item potency in event driven
architecture item potency ensures that
we that even if the same event is
processed multiple times it won't lead
to duplicate or unintended effects on
the
system this characteristic is crucial
for preventing creation of duplicate
records or actions which can occur in
complex
systems item potency also enhances the
overall reliability of the system by
ensuring consistent outcomes regardless
of the number of times an event is
processed typically item potency is
implemented using unique identifiers for
each event ensuring each event is
recognized and processed only once in a
meaningful way
a real world analogy for item potent
systems is pressing an elevator button
once you press an elevator button once
you press an unlit elevator button it
changes its state if you press it a
second time it doesn't unpress itself
nor can it do anything to speed the
system up so building on our
understanding of Eda terminology let's
now look at five key response models
these models dictate how systems
communicate and handle
Events first first we'll go through the
synchronous model familiar in
traditional apis where responses are
immediate and direct and essential for
real-time
interactions then the async Q where
events are queed for later processing
allowing the producer to move on without
waiting for the consumer's
response the broadcast model
disseminates events to multiple
consumers at once ideal for widespread
event
notification next the async bus Which
acts like a central Highway for events
supporting flexible multi-point
Communication in complex
systems and finally we have the async
router which intelligently directs
events based on specific rules inside of
the producer's code ensuring they reach
the appropriate
[Music]
destination the synchronous response
model is more like a traditional API
interaction a sender emits a request
which is received and process by the
receiver which then sends the response
back to the
sender this model is widely used and
understood in traditional application
architectures making it a familiar
choice for many
developers it allows for immediate error
detection as the sender can quickly know
if something goes wrong thanks to the
immediate
response the direct back and forth
communication typically ensures low
latency which is crucial for real-time
processing needs but in case in cases of
long processing times there's a risk of
timeout which can disrupt the flow of
information as the system scales
managing and balancing the load across
servers can become increasingly complex
this model often leads to tight coupling
making the system Le less flexible and
more prone to failure if any single
component
fails ensuring that operations can
safely can be safely repeated without
Crea in duplicates falls on the receiver
adding complexity to its
design a very common channel for
synchronous response model is the API
Gateway with an HTTP connection this is
a pivotal component in managing
synchronous
interactions API Gateway seamlessly
integrates with various AWS services and
it supports multiple authorization
mechanisms because of this even in the
subsequent asyn response models that
will go through more often than not
you'll still be proxying those requests
via API Gateway because of the multiple
authorization mechanisms and the service
Integrations that it
provides for synchronous responses the
channel also allows for request and
response
Transformations this feature is crucial
for adapting and formatting the data as
needed integration with Cloud watch also
enables real-time
monitoring a critical as aspect to note
is that the channel requires responses
within 30 seconds this constraint is
essential for maintaining system
efficiency and
reliability while the synchronous model
offers familiarity and immediate
feedback its limitations and scalability
and flexibility and complexity are
important considerations in your system
design to put this into the context of
our upcoming demo app let's talk about a
real world scenario
imagine a customer walks into a store to
check if our McGuffin is in
stock this customer represents the
sender in our model the store worker
akin to the API Gateway is approached
with the
query this worker has the responsibility
to provide immediate information just as
the API Gateway handles and routes the
requests so the warehouse worker checks
the inventory system and provides an
immediate response to the customer about
the items
availability this interaction is
synchronous mirroring the direct and
immediately response expected in the
synchronous
model however if the warehouse is huge
or the worker is busy it may take time
to get the response highlighting the
synchronous model's potential for
timeouts and real world
scenarios next let's discuss the async Q
response model here a producer sends
messages to a que and receives an
acknowledgement in return separately a
consumer pulls this Q to ret retrieve
messages also acknowledging once the
messages are
processed this model allows the receiver
to control the rate at which it
processes messages preventing
overload it accommodates processes
requiring longer compute times as
messages can wait in the
queue in the case of failures the model
also facilitates recovery as messages
remain in the queue until successfully
processed services like Amazon sqs can
offer item potency preventing duplicate
processing of messages
too but the model only provides
acknowledgement of responses which can
limit the information available about
message processing and while it Rec
while it enables recovery the time to
recover can be significant depending on
the Q size and processing
speed typically a single consumer
processes the que which can be a
bottleneck in high volume scenarios this
could be a single Lambda function spread
across multiple parallel
invocations but you would not have
different Lambda functions reading from
a
que despite being asynchronous there's
still a degree of tight coupling as the
consumer is directly dependent on the
q's structure and format it has to be
created and
exist in the context of async Q's our
main channel is sqs or simple Q
service simple Q service plays a crucial
role in scaling and fortifying the
architecture efficiently managing
message q and ensuring smooth
processing however with standard cues be
mindful of potential duplication and
ordering issues where messages might not
always be processed in the order they
were
sent sqs uses a polling model which can
introduce latency as consumers
periodically check for messages instead
of receiving them in real
time also there's a size limitation to
consider each message in sqs can be up
to 256
kiloby monitoring sqs is relying on
cloudwatch which provides insights into
the q's performance and message
flow now talking about a real world
analogy let's imagine our fictional apps
Warehouse has to send out a
McGuffin the warehouse producer sends
the McGuffin the message to the shipping
company
the Q from there the shipping company
manages the storage and eventual
delivery to the destination it receives
one McGuffin and delivers one McGuffin
it doesn't copy the McGuffin it's one:
one next we'll explore the broadcast
response model also known as publish
subscribe PBS
up the arc diagram here illustrates a
producer sending a message to a topic
and receiving an acknowledgement in
return this message is then
distributed from the topic to two
separate consumers showcasing the multi-
receiver capability of this model in
this case one message is copied and sent
to each
consumer in advantage of this model is
its ability to handle processes that
require extended computation without
burdening the
producer the model excels in scenarios
where one event needs to reach multiple
consumers as demonstrated in the
diagram it supports a variety of
communication protocols offering
adaptability to diverse system
requirements a challenge in this model
though is the potential for receiver
failure if a consumer fails it might
miss out on important broadcasted
events despite its broadcast nature
there's a level of tight coupling as
consumers need to to subscribe to
specific topics to receive
messages ensuring that a are processed
uniquely and not duplicated falls on the
consumer adding an extra layer of
complexity in the broadcast response
model our main channel is SNS or simple
notification
service SNS excels in one Dem many
messaging enabling a single message to
reach a wide array of recipients
simultaneously it operates on realtime
push base notifications ensuring
immediate dissemination of
information SNS uses a topic based Pub
sub model where messages are published
to topics and then pushed to
subscribers the service supports a
variety of subscribers in communication
protocols catering to different system
needs however it's important to note
that SNS does not inherently provide
message ordering or duplication handling
which might require additional handling
in the consumer's
logic for a real world analogy consider
our McGuffin Warehouse Inventory
management suppose the warehouse must
quickly update various departments sales
shipping customer service about changes
in the MCU and stock
levels when a new match of McGuffin
arrives or stock levels change a single
announcement is broadcasted to all
relevant
departments for event bus routing our
architecture diagram has a producer that
emits two typ types of messages new me
new user and updated
user these messages are sent to the
event Bridge bus where rules on each of
the types forward them to their type
specific
consumers there could potentially be a
third rule that forwards both event
types to another Lambda similar to SNS
this is a many to many situation where
many types of events can go on the bus
and each of those events can be D
directed to multiple
consumers a key advantage of this model
is its loose coupling producers and
consumers operate independently
enhancing system flexibility and
maintainability it's well suited for
processes requiring extended computation
as message processing is not tied to the
producer's
timeline like other async response
models one limitation is that the
response model primarily provides
acknowledgement responses which might
not offer detailed feedback on the
message
processing recovery from failures or
message losses is managed by the
consumer adding complexity to its
design and ensuring item potency or
preventing duplicate processing is also
up to the receiver which can be
challenging in complex event
scenarios for the async bust response
model our primary channel is Amazon
event
Bridge event Bridge excels in handling
complex event routing directing specific
events to the right destinations based
on detailed
criteria it offers seamless integration
with a wide range of AWS Services
enhancing the model's connectivity and
utility users can create custom event
buses tailored to their specific
application events offering greater
control and
customization the schema registry
feature AIDS in managing event models
ensuring consistency and Clarity in
event handling
one notable limitation is the lack of
direct support for message queuing
within eventbridge which may require
additional considerations for message
handling a real world analogy for the
async bus is very similar to the
broadcast scenario for stock levels
event Bridge routes specific events
based on Def defined criteria when stock
levels change in event could trigger
updates to the inventory team sales
department but not the sh shipping dock
because it didn't hit their the
threshold in their
rule each department is a consumer that
receives events based on their own set
of rules so it's a much more flexible
system than
SNS finally we have the async router a
multimodel event routing approach the
architecture diagram here illustrates a
producer that's not just emitting events
but also handling the routing logic it
routes events to the various response
models we've been discussing based on
its own internal business
logic a significant advantage of this
model is the greater control it provides
over the event
routing the producer directly manages
where and how events are routed allowing
for specific event
handling having said that its Advantage
is also a sign significant disadvantage
due to the extra complexity that you
have to add to the producer's code base
the model also introduced is tight
coupling as the producer is in
intricately linked with the routing
logic this type of system could be
exceptionally difficult to
maintain so Matt after having gone
through those the five different
response models like I don't know we've
already discussed going from kind of the
the synchronous mindset we've talked
about the flexibility moving to
Adventure bin architecture like should
teams just use event bridge by default
for everything as their starting point
in Eda or what what do you
think uh well I think event Bridge is a
fantastic service and I'm a huge fan of
uh it's many capabilities uh I I was a
little bit late to the pipes game
actually and and I'm now I'm just really
impressed with what you can do with
pipes and I can't wait to see what else
you can do with that in the future uh
that said uh there are number of other
tools that I think are really useful
here too and um so to say Let's uh throw
everything over event Bridge I think
sometimes um
what's so so definitely do use a vent
Bridge people should use a vent Bridge
uh when building a vent driven
architecture uh it's right there in the
name but but more than that it's it's a
really great service uh I think that
that
um there needs to be room here for step
functions as well uh step functions can
be a target for an event Bridge pipe or
just just a rule uh and uh but sometimes
you've got things that you want to
happen
in a certain sequence and if you're just
firing Events off uh you're just saying
here are here here's an event and then
I've got seven different listeners and
uh you know all those listeners are
going to do their own work right but
maybe I want to know when are all those
listeners done right well they can all
fire events too but that doesn't it
doesn't kind of come back together and
say okay everyone's done here is the uh
you know uh top level completionist I
would have to build something to do that
right I would have to track all of those
events coming back in the end and then
saying okay now I'm finally done I
finally reached the end of this uh it's
much easier to do something like that
with step function so you can fire the
event you can have a step function that
says okay I'm going to do all these
different things uh but I'm going to do
it within a container and then I'm going
to understand that that job has finished
and that then I can have my reporting I
can have my final status whatever
whatever needs to be done at the end of
that so I think those two things uh they
work really great together so I always
think about event Bridge as being like
if I if if system a needs to talk to
system B uh or something like that or
system a just needs to say hey something
happened who cares and then you can have
rules that that pick that up and do
things with that but if you've got uh I
need these seven things to happen and I
need them to happen in a certain
sequence I wouldn't just build that over
vent bridge I would definitely leverage
step functions for
yeah that's a good point and that
reminds me of uh like a Blog series or a
blog post by yanu the burning monk about
orchestration versus choreography which
basically covers the whole like should
you use event Bridge or should you use
step functions to depending on the task
yeah that's a great look at the
question I think you can mix and match
the two and I've written about this too
and I think Yan has also but uh like you
can combine the two by adding put event
notifications as part of your stuff step
functions flow too so you understand as
certain sections of the step function
completes you can maybe trigger things
yeah I don't I don't think we're getting
into that in this course uh maybe a
future one but but uh using past tokens
and stuff functions and sending uh those
out of vent bridge and then eventually
getting uh a response back to restart
your state machine uh it's a great
pattern I love using that yeah
awesome okay so uh our next section
we're going to switch over to demo mode
so we're going to go over uh migrating
our Legacy app into uh cdk well not into
cdk into event driven architecture all
right let's do
it so now that we know a bit more about
event driven architecture Basics let's
get into the actual
demonstration to do that we're going to
be using AWS cdk AWS cdk is a cloud
development kit it's an open-source
software it it's where you can write
imperative code to to generate
declarative cloud formation templates
now we just learned about the concept of
item potency and cdk is item potent the
same inputs that you give to a cdk stack
will yield the same exact cloud
formation yl if you somehow get into a
scenario where it's not and it's not
deterministic then you're doing
something wrong with cdk so you should
take a look at that um if you'd like to
if you haven't been exposed to cdk
before I've made the cdk crash course
for free code Camp before and linked at
mar.
codv
cdk all right so let's get back to our
whim system and look at uh the version
one of that system and the kinds of
problems that we had with it so uh so it
is a API Gateway Lambda Dynamo DB system
uh we got a couple of Lambda functions
here just just two for for demo purposes
but in the real world example you
probably have more uh and um we got to
check inventory function which is you
know pretty straightforward uh that
one's probably fine but but our um our
create order lamba function um it has a
few problems and the problems it um
really is is that it's trying to do too
much it's trying to do too much and it's
got um of course Lambda has a 15 minute
timeout nobody wants to wait 15 minutes
but we can anyway because um uh API
Gateway has a 29se second timeout so
that means that it has to do all of its
work within
window uh or that the user is going to
get a like a 504 error back so um it has
a couple of things that it's doing uh in
a Dynamo DB table it's saving in order
and it's updating the inventory uh and
those those ones are probably okay um
we'll come back to that in a second like
you can probably do do uh two um updates
to uh
um calls to Dynamo DB inside the Lambda
function uh but the the process payment
one is one one that we're really
concerned about so let's say our system
you know it it it does this thing it is
um uh we are calling our payment
microservice which is a separate service
that you know maybe another team
maintains and uh we know we understand
that that's an eventually consistent
thing it's not going to do all the the
the payment processing uh within the uh
uh request that the Lambda function is
making to it but uh it is uh let's say
it's uh not a a perfect uh microservice
it's a little bit slow sometimes uh and
sometimes we get rate limited sometimes
it just can't handle that the uh amount
of traffic that we send to it so this is
a really big problem now because our
Lambda function is going to try to call
the payment processing system and
sometimes it'll get rate limited so what
can we do we could we can do some
retries within the Lambda function we
have a very limited time window for
those retries and if we can't complete
the retries within the 30 seconds then
what's going to happen is that that our
user is going to get an error and
they're not going to know that this was
successful okay so that's a big problem
we have to fix that problem there's a
lot of different ways to fix that
problem uh but it is a it is a big
problem the other problem that we're
facing here is that um we're saving the
order we're updating inventory and then
we get a requirement that you
know uh we didn't restock our inventory
in time uh because we did know how low
it gotten because we had you know just a
door buster of a day of um selling the
guffins uh so what can we do we need
some kind of notification system that
lets us know when our inventory gets low
well one way we could do that is we
could say um after we do the adjustment
we could check the current level against
whatever you know our water mark is for
low inventory and if it were below that
we could uh post a message to SNS that's
going to send us an email to let us know
that our inventory is
low that's
um we it could work but our Lambda
function was doing three things now it's
going to be doing five things uh which
just means that there's more things that
could go wrong but the other problem
that H is what if our inventory gets
adjusted by something else maybe there's
like an admin override or something like
that or maybe uh there's other sales
channels or or something like that and
if the logic to send that notification
that we're low on inventor is only in
this function then any of those other
channels that that uh take our inventory
to that low level are not going to send
the notification so so basically that's
just really not a good solution and then
finally if you see the bottom of the the
diagram here uh we're thinking about
building this fulfillment
system um
but how do we know when there's a new
order uh based on the system we're going
to send another uh request out um you
know to notify that we're gonna have a
six thing that this Lambda function does
we're we're kind of um collapsing under
the weight of all the different things
that we're expecting to do here and we
really need to start sending us some
events because having an event that says
hey there's a new
order you want to do something with that
is going to be much more robust
architecture
all right so let's look at the uh at at
the adventure of inversion of this so we
made a few changes here first of all um
and we'll see this when we look at the
code uh we've gotten rid of some Lambda
functions we brought in another Lambda
function because you know we kind of
needed to
um we we switched to some uh direct
Integrations between API Gateway and
Dynamo DB and that's really because uh
the uh putting a Dynamo
put statement or or a a get item
statement or something like that in um
in an API Gateway uh template is really
pretty easy and it's not very much
different from putting it in land that
you avoid the cold starts uh and um you
know we we're we're basically stripping
down our system to make it much simpler
some people may not be comfortable with
that you can still use Lambda it's not
like a bad solution or something like
that but here we're just trying to strip
it down to the the uh bare minimum
now what we're doing is when we create
an order the first thing that we do is
we're going to persist that in the
database this is a little bit flipped
around from the way um many systems work
which is which is that okay an order
comes in uh we have a bunch of business
logic that we need to execute against it
and then we finally save it uh in a
table somewhere uh here what we're going
to do is we're going to say Okay order
comes in we immediately save it so we're
basically capturing ing the uh the user
intent in in what needs to happen later
on and then we're going to emit events
based on that right we don't have any
any additional logic at that stage we
just say store it send the event okay so
Dynamo DB streams are are a great
solution to this and a lot of this
architecture is based off that if you
happen to be using Dynamo DB uh it's a
good way to go um if you're not using
Dynamo DB you know you can emit events
in many other ways this is just a great
way to get started
so those who have used Dynamo DB streams
before know that uh it's recommended
that you only have two consumers of a
stream um and that has to do with
polling and and some some internal
concerns there uh a good solution to uh
or I guess a good pairing with Dynamo D
streams is to use a vent Bridge pipes
because you can subscribe the pipe to
the
stream and then from there you can you
can the the data that's coming through
you can you can transform it in
different ways you can do that with a
Lambda function or a step function you
can do that with um just a a very simple
mapping template if your need isn't that
complex and then uh that can be reposted
to event bridge and now you can create
rules to send it different places so in
our architecture uh we have the stream
coming through we're going to enrich the
the data in that stream so basically
what we're going to do is we're going to
um unmarshal the uh Dynamo DB tax to
make it a little bit easier to work with
later in the uh process um and then
we're going to repost that event back to
to uh event
Bridge from there we can create a rule
that is going to give us that low
inventory notification we'll show how
that works a little bit later it's very
cool I think uh we're going to store
event logs this is kind of a new thing
that wasn't in the old system but
anytime we have a change we're just
going to throw that into cloudwatch so
that we can uh see what are all the
different change events that are coming
through uh and of course Very
importantly here we still need to adjust
inventory and we still need to process
the payment we're going to use a step
function for that uh because we want
both of those things to happen and
they're kind of related U you know
pertinent to the order so uh the uh step
function is going to directly uh again
with with just a direct integration it's
going to make the uh inventory
adjustment um into Dynamo DB you can do
that with a condition statement to make
sure we don't end up with negative
inventory or something like that and um
and notice that that feeds back in we
get another change uh event which is
going to then uh be um encounter that
rule that will notify us if their
inventory got too low the last piece of
this uh is that we have put an uh sqsq
in between uh our order process and the
payment processing so that uh if uh if
we get rate limited uh the message
should stay on the Queue and and then
then getss consumed a little bit later
uh that's that's done by means of
another event Bridge pipe one thing I'll
mention is that that particular piece of
this architecture of of saying my
Downstream service might be rate
limiting me so let me uh put sqs and
aent Bridge pipes in between that it's
not something I've done production
before we might find that that doesn't
work as well as we thought it might we
might need a more robust solution that
could be swapped for a step function
later on and the rest of the
architecture doesn't have to change so
that's that's a really great thing about
uh uh event driven architecture is that
you can uh replace components that
aren't quite living up to what you
expected them to do and the rest of the
the architecture doesn't have to
change on this diagram just wanted to
show uh that um you know the motion here
where we had a Lambda function that was
doing uh check inventory in the V1
architecture in V2 uh we're doing that
as a direct integration it's almost the
same thing uh but that save order it was
doing multiple things before now we have
single responsibility components so we
have a direct integration that that
processs the order in our table uh and
then we've got the Dynamo stream that
eventually uh eventually but very
quickly actually uh uh will trigger that
stuff function that is going to do the
inventory
adjustment um that we've got a um some
new features here we got we got our low
inventory notification that's very easy
to implement uh and uh we can build that
external a fulfillment system based on
the um on the event we've got event logs
uh and we've got that cue for our
payment
processing and while we're at it we
could think about additional events that
we could add to this system what if we
wanted a high inventory warning that
that says that we've overstocked and our
sales team needs to get active what if
we want an out of stock uh notific if
that that then can can flag that in our
catalog is uh on back order there
there's lots of different uh things that
we could conceive of and they're all
going to be fairly easy to implement and
um and and fit this
model all right everybody let's look at
some code so what I have here is the uh
whims V1 system that's the the rest API
based system uh and um this is the cdk
code so I'm just going to walk through
this really quickly there's not a lot
here um and you'll be able to do the
GitHub later on I suggest you check that
out might a little bit different by then
but it's going to be mostly the same
thing so uh we've got a table construct
we're going to create uh our Dynamo DB
table uh that's that's pretty
straightforward
um i' I've uh winged and moaned a little
bit about the payments API uh for demo
purposes what I did is I just created a
lock integration in a separate rest API
uh that always returns a 200 uh actually
that seems like a pretty nice service
but it doesn't actually do a lot I I
added some throttling to that just for
fun uh so we can Benchmark that um then
I created a couple Lambda functions
there's the one to get inventory and the
one to uh create orders we look at the
source for those get inventory um is
super
simple um so I'm using the uh Dynamo DB
document client and um I'm just going
and getting a specific item so there's
one item in the table uh for each
inventory now probably I would do
something a little we probably have more
than one thing that we can sell uh and
there'd probably be some kind of uh
query pram or something like that that
includes the the um skew or something
and we we use that to uh actually
generate a query but in this case just
to keep it really simple there's exactly
one thing and so we're just going to go
get that and it's going to tell us what
that inventory number is all right uh
create ORD is a little bit more complex
um we still got Dynamo DB document
client here and uh first of all we're
going to toss that guy in our table uh
we're going to generate a uh um
partition key and sort key for that
we're also going to set the status of it
to pending uh you won't actually see
that status change in this demo but you
can imagine that some other system later
on would update that then we also have
to have an update command uh that's
going to go and uh reduce the inventory
for that
um and finally we're going to make a uh
fetch call uh using native node fetch to
uh post our order over to the payment
system and uh and and get that payment
process started then we return order
created and uh everybody's happy right
uh the only other things that you would
see in this stack are uh just a couple
really quick things we've got our our
rest API for the orders API uh we've got
a couple of resources there to connect
to the Lambda integration and then
finally there's this AWS custom resource
which is uh is just to seed the database
so that when I deploy my stack I'm going
to have it preceded with that LX model
McGuffin uh with a quantity of 1 million
items all right so let's walk through
the modern architecture uh it's going to
be pretty different here um first of all
what I did is um the V1 version of whims
uh had everything just inside of that
whims stack class uh our V2 version has
a few more things going on and so what I
did is I I built some L3 constructs uh
L3 constructs um combine uh various
things uh other resources that I want to
create uh and and kind of put them
behind my own uh vision of of what the
application actually looks like so the
the so those are just really in this
case uh I'm not anticipating any reuse
it's just sort of an
organizational uh construct so I still
left the um the table here I could have
created uh an L3 construct just for the
table but it would really be exactly the
same as this L2 construct so it's just
fine to do that the only thing I might
uh save a few lines here of uh of config
hardly worth it as um you can see that
I've only got a little over 40 lines of
uh total code here so let's look at some
of these individual um sections of it
the first is CDC which is uh course
stands for change data
capture and we've got several things
happening here um I'm declaring a
node.js
function uh which is called CDC
enrichment let's just check that one out
uh really quickly and um basically what
this is doing is it's um we're borrowing
the um unmarshal utility from util
Dynamo DB and we're using that to uh to
transform our Dynamo DB record into
something that's a little bit easy into
pure Json because Dynamo DB always
specifies the type uh in a way that is a
little obtuse to work with later on so
that's that's really all this is doing
we could do other things here if we
wanted to this is just code and we could
do anything that we want uh um we are uh
adding a meta tag that that lets us know
what process this um we're adding this
data key and so then we're kind of
putting this in in a a format that's
going to make sense to us in a schema
that will uh be happening later on so
that's um that's the function that is
going to be enriching what happens in
the pipe let's let's look at what the
pipe is here so so um Matt for the
enrichment function is that what's the
output of that going to like what is so
it's outputting a list right it's
processing a bunch of
Records what does that list end up
becoming uh so the output of the
enrichment function uh is sent to the
Target of the
pipe and for this specific pipe the
target's event Bridge right so the the
response list is going to end up being
the details of all the events that will
be going out that's right that's a
really good point to
make all right so let's go back and look
at our pipe construct uh at the time
that we're making this
recording uh there is not an L2 pipe
construct so we are forced to fall back
to CFM we're not actually forc because
there is an RFC for an L2 pipe construct
it's still in uh RFC status uh you can
use it uh I have used it it's it's kind
of good uh I went with CFM pipe um just
because it's not actually part of the
cdk just yet uh and CFN pipe is okay to
use you have to do a little bit more
manual stuff for example I have to
create a role explicitly uh because CFN
pipe is going to want the Arn of that
role just the thing that it does uh I
added a bunch of log configuration here
it's a little bit optional but it's
really good especially when it comes to
debugging as I had to do uh to do that
um you can see that there's an
enrichment key here um which that's
going to expect uh the function Arn um
the L2 construct would just take a
function as an argument in this case
because this is uh the uh corresponds
directly to Cloud information it's going
to want the Arn
um we set the source here so the source
is going to be that table stream uh this
subscribes the pipe to the Dynamo DB
stream uh which is configured
here in our table V2
construct we're setting some parameters
here a batch size of 10 which means that
we'll we will not process more than 10
times uh 10 items at a time and our
starting position will be the most
recent change uh we are targeting this
back to the same uh event bus which is
going to be our default
bus uh as discussed
previously and uh we're adding some
additional parameters that this will
help us to Route the event when we
create a rule for this our change data
capture all it's doing is it's it's
saying there's a stream of data coming
in it could be uh a um a creation event
it could be an update it could be a
deletion uh and um we're going to use
our Lambda function to enrich that just
because the uh the uh transform
capabilities and the vent Bridge pipes
isn't really up to what we wanted to do
for this uh for our purposes here and
then we're going to send that back to to
uh event bridge if we never created a
rule for it it would just kind of never
go anywhere from here but our other
components can start to build those
rules so let's look at
those here we have the our order
processor construct um we're going to
grab that uh default event
bu and
um we're declaring a machine I kind of
um there's a few different ways to do
this in in cdk I I like to use the
constructs uh and um so we've got a
parallel construct here not much to say
about it and then we've got an update uh
Dynamo update item construct here now
this is really not very different from
uh using the SDK and typescript so I'm
pretty comfortable doing it this could
be a Lambda function that does this
instead uh and um in this case uh this
was actually missing from the V1
architecture so uh that's another little
Improvement that you get here there's a
condition expression here that makes
sure that we're not uh uh committing
more quantity than we actually have uh
so this would fail if we had 99 stock
and tried to sell 100 uh and um assuming
that condition is successful then we are
going to reduce uh the
quantity uh our other Branch here is
that is is basically we're just going to
take that uh that message body that came
in and we're going to replay that on SQ
we're going to stick stick that in the
queue whoever subscribes to that queue
we don't know at this point uh we're
just um sending it off and then
uh how does this thing get triggered in
the first place well here's the rule
that does that now we're uh we've got
that source and event type that we set
uh in our CDC construct and here we are
going to um uh create this rule uh make
sure that we're only getting insert uh
event types and that our comption key
begins with customer uh and uh we could
we could uh further refine that if we
wanted to and then we're going to Target
our state machine so the event now
becomes the input to the state
machine let's look at the our payments
API so I moved that
um I moved that mocked integration API
here um as as well as the uh the
throttle plan
this is really unchanged uh just wanted
to make sure that it had its own
construct the payments process there is
the
um piece that's a little bit more
interesting
here uh because we got another CFN pipe
uh with its own role and its own uh
logging
solution
uh this is this is the queue that uh is
going to um consume
messages uh the messages go into the uh
into the
pipe uh but this pipe instead of
replaying an event over event Bridge
which actually come to think of it is
probably the way I would like for uh our
payment system to work but somebody else
is working on that or nobody's working
on that so it's payment system isn't
going to change much uh in this cut so
what we're going to do is we're going to
Target that API Gateway uh with this so
we can actually have our pipe connect
sqs messages come off the queue and we
we pull them in we're going to replay
that to API Gateway and uh that way we
can manage our our rate limit
of couple more constructs here to go
through uh our inventory monitor uh this
one is is uh is really nice so all we
have to do is is um we're grabbing our
bus again uh it's just the default bus
that uh already exists in the account we
are
um creating
SNS topic with an email subscription so
that our team can be notified when when
this event goes out and then we're going
to create another rule here but this
rule has a numeric uh comparator so we
say if our inventory is is less than or
equal to 100 items 100 units uh then
we're going to trigger this
rule finally we've got uh
this observability construct and um this
creates another event rule uh event
Bridge rule uh that is going to um store
all of our events in uh a cloudwatch log
group and it's going to create an event
Bridge
archive uh and
um uh and schema registry for all the
events that we're sending yes so I just
want to um I've got the view here of my
Dynamo DB table in my account where I've
deployed the whim system and I just want
to kind of give a really quick demo here
of how it can work so
um uh you can see that I have uh
preseeded my database I've got I've got
my LX McGuffin uh ready to roll and I've
got a thousand uh items in
stock over here is um my so here over
here in Postman I'm
um going to uh create a post uh to the
orders API in order to create uh a new
order so I've got set my customer ID to
123 and the quantity is three and
presumably there' be some more
interesting information here um so if I
send that
over and then I flip back to my table
you can see that
um I have uh registered my order and my
quantity has already been decremented so
so it was that quickly it was even
faster than that that that um my state
machine ran and all the other pieces uh
uh happened and uh so it almost seems
like it's uh probably even as fast as it
was before so what happened behind the
scenes well one of the things we know it
was uh that my my step function ran um
and so this is this is the step function
you can see that it's um got uh parallel
two branches in the parallel step here
one of them is adjust inventory and the
other one's in key payment
uh they were both successful um what I
think is really cool about this is is is
look at how fast uh this thing was it
was uh 136 milliseconds uh from start to
end uh and this thing just just really
blazed uh it it got the work done very
very quickly and um because this is an
Express uh step machine step function uh
that means that it's going to be very
very cheap in fact really the
um unless I'm I'm doing this quite a lot
which would be a good problem to have
let's face it because that means I'm
selling quite a lot it's the the cost of
running this is going to be
negligible an x-ray uh we have a little
bit of a problem here which I hope is is
a problem that service teams ultimately
solve for us and that is that uh you
actually don't get to trace over a
Dynamo DB stream so um in this case you
can you can do traces over event Bridge
um but the the stream kind of ends the
trace so so we see the initial Trace
here which is that our client has placed
an order and that's going to hit the
Dynamo DB we'd really love to see a line
that comes from Dynamo DB over to the uh
which really the stream and the pipe
here is is the client we triggering the
state machine and we can see that we're
um uh doing another operation on our
whims table uh we're putting something
in
sqs uh but there's obviously some
missing pieces here so that means that
uh really it uh in the end here we're
going to have to kind of uh put together
some uh some kind of additional
observability elements that will let us
know hey we had uh you know X orders
come in and uh y ended up in this status
and and Z ended up in this status
because we don't get the full Trace here
uh we do get good traces for you know if
we want to
uh uh do it dive down and uh look at
okay just just that initial save or or
something like that like if we start
seeing error or something in this area
this is a great tool for that but
unfortunately it doesn't yet give us the
whole end end
view so Matt if I was a team
implementing this what approach should
we take to iteratively do it should we
maybe start with the observability
construct and the change data capture or
is there a better
approach so those are both uh you know
the great thing about those constructs
is that they're completely
non-destructive right they're just
adding additional information the
observability construct is going to
start registering events and and uh give
you some additional logging and and the
CDC right until you subscribe to that
event and do something meaningful with
it uh you could you could Implement that
and then just see what it does and see
how you like it and see whether it makes
sense to you you data capture stuff uh
independently of everything get this get
those events flowing and then even skip
the stuff and like automate the
Fulfillment part or automate the low
inventory notification part without even
touching the existing V1 code and then
absolutely or you spread it out and have
multiple teams you know one adding the
Fulfillment one adding the inventory
another an intern you know adding the
step function or whatever that's
correct I guess calling out one more
thing the the distributed nature the
like decoupled nature of this if
ultimately business comes back and
doesn't want to know about low inv low
inventory notifications for example you
can just delete that construct and you
don't have to go in and modify the
original Lambda the order processing
Lambda like that
it's right right I mean I think I think
that's
um you know to to think of your overall
application platform as a a series of
components all of which are are
replaceable is a great architectural
mindset to have because it just makes it
makes pivots it makes new requirements
it makes you know maybe the the state of
play has changed in some way uh and it's
and you know you have to respond to uh
new new business pressures and if your
architecture is uh is modular enough
then that's going to be a lot easier to
do than if uh you've just got sort of
like this
uh you know sprawling classes and
functions uh that are much harder to
iterate
on now let's move on to Advanced
practices for event
architecture proper event formatting is
crucial for maintaining system integrity
scalability and
interoperability enforce strict backward
compatibility in your event structures
this approach reduces the risk of
breaking changes and ensures smoother
evolution of your
systems keep your event properties
consistent across all events consistency
AIDS in predictability and eases
integration across different parts of
the
system avoid optional properties in your
event schemas ensuring that all
properties are mandatory simplifies
processing logic and reduces
ambiguity ensure that event sources are
consistent within a single code
Repository
this consistency is key to traceability
and manageability of
events different code repositories
should not emit the same Event Source
unique sources prevents conflicts and
improves Clarity in event
handling build a standard metadata
object for all events this metadata
should include essential information
like the event type the Tim stamp and
source
providing a uniform context for each
event place your actual event payload
under a dedicated data object this
separation ensures that the payload is
clearly distinguishable from the
metadata let's talk about what should be
in the metadata of an event
detail include item potency IDs in the
metadata these unique identifiers ensure
that each event is processed only once
preventing duplicate processing and
enhancing reliability
it's essential to track where events
originate you can use identifiers like
the default Lambda environment variables
the AWS lamed a function name or things
like the step function execution ID and
store those in the metadata object this
tracking provides Clarity on the event
journey and AIDS in debugging and
monitoring for more insights into
effective event payload patterns you
could check out David Bo's blog post
which offers valuable perspectives I
also wrote a blog post not long ago
delving into inferring architecture by
using the metadata from event
details a as an example of a well
structured detail object The Meta object
here includes incoming details like the
account source and detail type as well
as the function name and state machine
or job
identifiers this structure AIDS in
tracking The Event Source and
path under the data object we would
place the actual payload of the event
and this clear separation between the
metadata and the payload simplifies
processing and
interpretation when producing events
there are two primary types full and
sparse understanding the differences in
applications of each is key to efficient
event
management sparse events carry minimal
information about what occurred they're
lightweight and typically include just
enough data to identify the event and
its basic
context the advantage of sparse events
is their Simplicity and reduce load on
the system making them efficient for
high volume or real-time
scenarios in contrast full events are
more detailed including extra
information that might minimize the need
for subsequent
queries while they can be more
convenient by providing comprehensive
data up front they can also increase the
computation burden on the producer and
can be heavier on the
network there's a spectrum between full
and sparse events the choice of which
you to use uh depends on the specific
requirements of your
system such as response time Network
bandwidth and data processing
needs remember with extra information
comes more risk more data can lead to
increased complexity potential privacy
concerns and a higher chance of data
becoming stale or or
irrelevant regardless of the type chosen
it's crucial to avoid breaking changes
in your event schema ensure backward
compatibility to maintain system
stability and
reliability when designing events in
event driven architecture it's crucial
to
consider the nature and handling of the
data within your
payloads as a general rule avoid
including sensitive information in event
payloads exposing such data can pose
security risks and compliance
issues if sensitive data must be
included consider encrypting it at the
field level this approach helps preserve
the ability to perform pattern matching
while safeguarding the sensitive
data be mindful of payload limits for
instance Amazon event Bridge has a
payload limit of 256
kiloby if your event data exed ceeds
this limit an alternative strategy is to
upload the larger data to S3 and then
emit an event containing the bucket and
key
combination this method not only
circumvents the payload limit but also
leverages the robust storage
capabilities of
S3 remember if you're using S3 buckets
consumers of your events will need
independent access permissions to read
from these buckets ensuring appropriate
access controls and permissions is
critical to maintain security and
functionality change data capture events
are a pivotal aspect of event driven
architecture particularly when dealing
with database
changes these events are produced in
response to modifications in a database
providing a real-time data stream
reflecting these
changes key to change data capture is
creating a consistent event
interface these interfaces typically
include information like the columns
that were changed and stringified
representations of data values before
and after the change the
diffs such structured information helps
in understanding the nature and impact
of changes made to the
database I've written some blog posts
that can help with this on Aurora if you
have an aurora mySQL database you could
use binlog streaming as a source for
your change data capture events or for
MySQL or postgress you could also use
the database migration service and pipe
the events to Kinesis and from there go
to event Bridge or
wherever fortunately Dynamo DB is much
simpler and you can just leverage Dynamo
DB streams to create events these can be
efficiently integrated with event Bridge
pipes for seamless event
handling to the right is is an example
of a change data capture
structure in my example I made the
detail type CDC update and in the
details data portion I included the
information about the source of the
change the database and table along with
a list of columns
changed and before and after attributes
with stringified
Json we use stringified Json for the
before and after fields to keep the
interface
consistent if the event bus has schema
registry enabled and the before and
after Fields were not strings a new
version in the schema registry would get
created for every combination of field
change but with the stringified format
we have the information we need between
the combination of columns changed and
before and after and we maintain a a
common
interface I'll note that a CDC insert
event would not have the before
attribute and a CDC delete event would
not have an after attribute they aren't
optional in these cases because they are
different detail types they're different
interfaces
hey editor Matt here I just want to
point out that stringified before and
after bodies aren't necessarily for
everyone it's a consideration if you
want to have maintained consistent
interfaces but what it does do is it
breaks event pattern matching inside of
the Deltas so for example in our demo
app we actually didn't stringify the
data and we used the change values
inside of the change data cap capture
event to do the low inventory
notification so that's an important
consideration for how you want to manage
your change data capture events and
whether or not you care about the schema
registry schema registry incrementing
the version every time at the end of the
day it's probably not a big deal I I did
want to point it
out event pattern filtering plays a
critical role in efficiently routing and
handling events event Bridge off highly
flexible event pattern rules these can
be these can include various patterns
such as using a prefix suffix Wild Card
anything but in numeric and
others such versatility allows for
precise event matching according to
specific
criteria best practices indicate that
you should be cautious to avoid writing
patterns that could create infinite
Loops in event triggering another event
in a cyclical manner that could lead uh
to system overload and unpredict ible
changes you also want to make sure your
event patterns are as precise as
possible vague patterns may lead to
unintentional matching causing noise and
inefficiencies in event
processing always specify the Event
Source and detail type in your filters
this practice Narrows down the event
scope ensuring only relevant events are
processed include the account and region
as filters for enhanced security too
utilize Conta filters to further refine
event selection focusing on specific
event attributes or values within the
event
payload a schema registry can play an
important role in managing and
maintaining the structure of event data
in event driven
architectures it ensures a consistency
Clarity and compatibility across
different parts of the
system start by defining clear and
concise schemas at the beginning of your
project early definition helps in
establishing a strong foundation for
your event your event data
structures an Implement Version Control
for your schemas as your system evolves
Version Control ensures that changes are
tracked and managed
systematically regularly enforce schema
validation this practice helps in
Catching inconsistencies and errors
early maintaining the Integrity of your
data keep a detailed record of any
changes made to your
schemas proper documentation is crucial
for understanding the evolution of your
event structures and for
troubleshooting Implement notifications
for schema changes this keeps all the
stakeholders informed about
modifications ensuring that everyone is
aligned with the latest schema
updates and finally consider using tools
like event catalog by David Bo for
managing your event schemas the async
API initiative is another valuable
resource resource it provides tools and
standards for managing asynchronous
apis many AWS Services emit events to
your account's default event bus and
event
Bridge these events can range from
changes in service states to specific
actions executed within the
services you can create powerful
automation within your AWS accounts
tapping into these default events this
enables real-time responsive actions
based on service
activities to effectively document and
manage these previously I wrote a
three-part blog series on event driven
documentation where I tied into these
AWS Service events to automatically
update my org's documentation anytime a
cloud information stack deployed with
event Bridge rules or API
gateways
in event Bridge there are two types of
buses the default bus that is included
in every AWS account and custom named
buses understanding their difference is
key to effective event
management the default bus is always
available ensuring a foundation for
loose coupling and better collaboration
it receives AWS Service events
automatically making it ideal for
integration across multiple services and
teams Custom Custom named buses offer
more control tailored to specific
requirements while they provide tighter
Access Control they are more challenging
to share making them better suited for
single teams or projects with specific
access
needs while custom named buses have
their place I recommend prioritizing the
use of the default bus wherever possible
for its EAS of collaboration and Broad
integration
capabilities event Bridge pipes is a
feature in AWS that simplifies
point-to-point
Integrations between event sources and
targets it is designed to reduce the
complexity and coding requirements in
developing event-driven
architectures you can create a pipe to
receive events from supported sources
and optionally add filters for specific
event processing further you can Define
enrichments to enhance event Data before
sending it to your chosen
Target pipes support various
Integrations including Lambda functions
step functions and API calls allowing
for versatile and dynamic event
handling for example a pipe can link an
Amazon sqs message CU to an AWS step
function State machine with an event
Bridge API destination for data
enrichment
this setup exemplifies efficient
Automation in a e e-commerce
context so Matt now that we've come to
the end and learned so much about event
driven architecture what's next how do
people get started doing
this so I I think uh kind of as we
talked about it in the demo a little bit
like an easy way is to just start
producing events even if you don't have
consumers to to use them um you can do
that by adding and change data capture
depending on what system your your
database is on or you could if you have
uh a server full or a server L system
both could just start putting events on
the event rout bus right um and I think
it Segways really easily uh to once you
get towards like decoupling your system
by emitting events like you can really
segue into domain driven development and
really break things up into like
teens um there's the there's a concept
called event storming also that you
could kind of approach with your team to
see how you can break things up into
domain driven
development have have you used uh event
storming or domain driven development in
your workplaces sure yeah um I mean I
think we we definitely uh you know need
to think about the the business
domains uh that drive our applications
in order to to make sure that we're
working on the most important uh things
so um so so considering uh the business
domains that we have to work with you
know like
oftentimes uh that becomes a discussion
about microservices or uh banded
contexts but I think that um you know
thinking thinking that in terms of
events
because whether or not we're using event
Bridge whether or not we're using event
driven architecture of course we have
lots of events right like uh you know
click streams like you know different
things that happen in the system
identifying and naming business events
that we care about as things that uh you
know become features of the system as
opposed to sort of like a side effect uh
that of some code I think is a really
strong pattern uh to start to make sense
of your system like some of us uh have
uh work on systems that have been around
for a little while and and sometimes
they sort of grow up in strange
different ways and you end up with
feature sets that uh don't exactly make
perfect sense if you start creating
events and you start saying this is an
order event or or this is a uh you know
application submission event or whatever
your business may be uh that um I I
think that's a great way to start making
sense of things and then you can start
pulling you know you may have had a
function that does nine different things
uh because that's the way the system was
built once you have that event you can
start taking some of those things out of
that big
function and have them instead triggered
by the
event awesome but it also sounds like
we're touching on our next uh free code
Camp course if we make a domain driven
one all right let's do
it and I think that about wraps it up so
again uh We've linked it throughout the
course but there's a companion blog post
at mars.
codde um there's also a lot of really
great resources at serverless land.com
including different serverless patterns
that you can use with event-driven
architecture and other serverless
concept Concepts event driven
architecture isn't specific to
serverless but it certainly helps uh
there's an awesome talk from Eric
Johnson at rein from from reinvent and
this short code links to that march. Cod
EJ and David Bo does a lot of blog posts
about avender and architecture he has
some really awesome stuff about like
different patterns with it and different
tool sets he's made things like the
event catalog to help with documentation
and the event the event Cannon um that
can help you you know test your own
event structures and everything like
that so he also has a reinvent talk
about his journey to event driven
architecture and that's I have a short
link to that at mar. codes SL DB and
then my own blog is at matt. mars. codes
and Matt Morgan's links to his talks and
all his blog posts and everything is at
Matt morgan.
Cloud so thanks to free code Camp uh for
hosting uh this video and um and thanks
to you Matt Mars for inviting me to join
you uh and especially thanks for doing
all the editing because I would be bad
at that it would take me a really long
time so I'm glad else is doing that uh
it's been fun um uh anyone who enjoyed
this and wants to continue your learning
find me on LinkedIn uh find my website
uh happy to engage with you and uh help
continue your
learning yeah likewise everything Matt
said uh I'm on socials I'm Mart's codes
on pretty much most of them including
LinkedIn so feel free to reach out to me
there I think we'll try to monitor the
comments once the video is out and
definitely check out the companion blog
post that we'll be hosting alongside
this U that will also have the code
references and everything too so yeah
thanks Matt thanks for code Camp hope
everyone uh learned a bit about event
driven
architecture bye
bye
and and learn so much about event Bridge
driven architecture
that was stupid I said event Bridge
driven
architecture you should see my blooper
real for enhanced security and context
specific
specif Eric Johnson is a renowned
principal developer
at Eric Johnson is a renowned principal
developer advate wow I can't say
that Eric Johnson is a renowned
prent bloop
real Eric Johnson is a renowned look at
the
camera Eric Johnson is a renowned
P all
right it's just the producer directly
manages where and how events are routed
allowing
for
specific event handling let's see if I
can edit
that a signic
uh
okay here Postman I'm going to make a uh
a post to my API Gateway uh to create a
new
payment
and
sorry cut
that event Bridge
offers not sure what that's supposed to
say